British Prime Minister Theresa May is
coming under fresh pressure over her
handling of brexit media including The
Sunday Times say that Mays own cabinet
is plotting to oust her while there was
little sign of that pressure as may
visit a church with her husband this
morning she's reportedly planning a
last-ditch attempt to win support among
lawmakers for her brexit deal which
Parliament has rejected twice for more
on that we're joined now by our
correspondent Birgit moss in London May
faces increasing pressure
Birgit to resign how likely is that to
happen there's everything going on as we
speak I mean she's meeting with cabinet
ministers we know there is a lot of
pressure on her and her authority is
really draining away by the day maybe
even by the hour but will she really
resign we don't know she's been
extraordinarily resilient over the past
years there were many moments where
other Prime Minister's probably would
have gone but she's toughen it out she
seems determined to try once more to get
her deal through Parliament but as you
say the voices are getting louder for
her to go
how would May stepping down actually
solve the problem that's a good question
because over breaks it the country and
the Parliament is so fundamentally
divided that it's difficult to see a
solution coming out of this whole mess
Theresa May has been accused of not
looking for a consensus of very early in
the brexit process determining her own
red lines which point Awards a fairly
hard break did not know membership in
the single market or in the customs
union and to just plow through with it
and now we see that she really does not
have any consensus for her policy so we
know that Parliament is looking for a
solution but they're also still Theresa
May loyalists who hope that the deal
will go through let's listen what Philip
Hammond the Chancellor had to say about
this in just over two weeks time we
run the risk of facing a very stark
choice between leaving the EU with no
deal or not leaving the EU at all it is
essential that we get a deal done well
and this deal most likely to be
presented to Parliament for at that time
two defeats already that weight on this
deal that she has hammered out with the
European Union is likely to happen next
week Berger it seems for months now
people have been reading tea leaves you
know looking into crystal balls pick
your metaphor I'm gonna ask you to do it
now what's likely going to happen here
well my bet is on the deal going to go
in front of Parliament at least it
doesn't seem very likely that it will
get voted on it doesn't seem like she
does have the support this time around
and that obviously begs the question
what happens then Parliament is working
hard MPs are trying to come to some sort
of alternative solution to hard year but
we also know that it's you know it's
it's so hard for them to find a
compromise and we can't really see this
that anything is sort of taking shape as
yet and there's only a few days left so
like like Philip Hammond has said if
there is no no solution to this it's
still the case that now at the 11th of
April the UK will leave the European
Union and lawmakers are determined to
find some sort of solution to the crisis
but it's far from certain that they will
succeed in that
thank you Burgin mas in London